consequently the conservatives did not
realize what was happening on the
cultural front
they didn't realize that education was
being redefined
from the transmission of a culture down
through the generations
to teaching your children that your
culture was fundamentally illegitimate
racist
and should be obliterated they didn't
realize that was going on
they didn't realize that the freedom
to junk your husband the freedom to
have a baby without a father even
without the baby
even knowing who his father was and
perhaps you didn't know who the father
was
that that freedom would come with a
terrible cost uh
to the child and to the woman and also
to the man
they didn't figure all that out and all
sorts of other stuff so
they just lost the plot and then
having vacated the cultural battleground
they then observed that society was
changing in that direction and they said
oh we can't do anything to stop this
it's like canute holding back the tide
we must go with the flow of cultural
change
when you see what is happening
across the world right now and how
liberalism has sort of failed and that
what that then probably leads to
is sort of some version of right-wing
authoritarianism or something like that
if you agree with that
premise um what what can we do
if if you want to save liberalism right
now what what can people do
well it's this paradox uh again
that to save liberalism you have to uh
be conservative
um and i do believe that
the problem uh uh that that that the the
sort of death throes of liberalism
have been caused not just by the uh
what's happened to the left
or the progressive circles in the west
but by the fact that the people who are
supposedly
who are supposed to be defending the
west
uh against this onslaught um have
thrown in the towel a long time ago
largely through ignorance
um there aren't
there are not precise parallels between
british conservatives and
american republicans but nevertheless
there are certain i think
uh uh constant characteristics that
um the conservative wing of politics if
i can put it that way
has forgotten what it is in business to
conserve
um and especially i think since the
uh the fall of the soviet union uh which
i think was taking place
before the berlin wall actually fell you
know the soviet union clearly was
you know in its death throes for a long
time before that
and i think that what happened was that
um that conservative
conservatively minded individuals or
certainly conservative politicians the
conservative political class
uh when the conservative when the soviet
union fell it sort of thought
oh our fox has been shot what do we do
now
we've won um here is you know the soviet
union having disintegrated it's no
longer a threat
everyone's bought into the market now
the problem with conservatives
is that they tend to think entirely in
terms of economics
um they don't think in terms of culture
they don't understand what edmund burke
understood during the french revolution
it's all about culture it's all about
values it's all about moral values they
don't think like that
and they haven't thought of that for
years so they thought well what do we do
now
everyone's brought into the market what
um
are we going to hang our hat on now and
they are lighted upon
freedom and i remember this happening at
the time and i thought oh
my oh no they've they've had it
this is ridiculous because the left hung
its hat
on freedom so what happened was that
while the left
venerated uh and worshipped the shrine
of
personal individual freedom freedom to
do
exactly what i like behave as i like
had the values that i like and no one
can tell me that i'm wrong
conservatives uh said that everything
that's good in the world is going to be
delivered by the free market
and consequently the conservatives did
not realize what was happening on the
cultural front
they didn't realize that education was
being redefined
from the transmission of a culture down
through the generations
to teaching your children that your
culture was fundamentally illegitimate
racist
and should be obliterated they didn't
realize that was going on
they didn't realize that the freedom
to junk your husband the freedom to
have a baby without a father even
without the baby even knowing who his
father was and perhaps you didn't know
who the father was
that that freedom would come with a
terrible cost
to the child and to the woman and also
to the man
they didn't figure all that out and all
sorts of other stuff so they just
lost the plot and then having vacated
the cultural battleground they then
observed that society was changing in
that direction and they said
oh we can't do anything to stop this
it's like canute holding back the tide
we must go with the flow of cultural
change
and so they became part of the problem
and
that's why liberalism was allowed to
become the kind of
monster that it has become which is
illiberalism
or as somebody who was a very
uh distinguished thinker once coined the
term and it's so true
cultural totalitarianism is what we're
living through
my friend michael malus who's a
brilliant political thinker he's more of
like a
anarchist type but he says that
conservatism is just liberalism
uh at the speed limit which i think is
partly
partly what you're getting to there do
you sense that something has
shifted though because i do sense right
now
that it's partly because of trump maybe
90
because of trump although maybe trump is
just the symptom of it
but that conservatives have started to
understand
the cultural part i i think there is a
sense of if you look online the things
that are fun and funny and the memes and
comedy
the left has destroyed all of these
things through its totalitarian view
and the things that are actually
interesting right now
are things that are coming out of more
right leaning circles
do you first cred do you credit trump
for breaking through that thing in a way
that the conservatives would have never
done
otherwise i think the election of donald
trump was the
uh the outcome uh of a change that
had already taken place um that is to
say
um there are i think that there were two
shoes that fell
that south right metaphor in 2016.
one was the brexit vote in britain and
the other was the election of donald
trump
and on both occasions i think what
happened obviously they're very
different from
different different phenomena um
different countries
but they were fueled by the same thing
which was that the vast
bulk of ordinary people the millions and
millions and millions of
when i say ordinary people i mean the
kind of people who don't have
typically a higher university education
um and who have who had spent
decades being preached at and being
scorned and being vilified and being
produced
by the intelligentsia which dominates
completely
the universities and the media
and the whole cultural apparatus and
more than that
dominated politics because even the
so-called conservatives the conservative
party and britain republicans in america
didn't really differ that much in these
cultural uh
uh issues uh from the left and they were
all basically
saying to the people you don't know what
you're talking about you're just
rednecks you're just stupid
you don't even have a university
education you're bigoted you don't
what you you don't like immigrants
you're racist
so the the things that ordinary people
value which is community which is
the attachment to their country
patriotism love of their country
and the kind of instinctive
understanding that a country and a
culture
is made up of people who share your own
values you don't they don't have to
look like you they can be different
color faces from you they can be
different ethnic backgrounds from you
but at some important
juncture they share the most important
values
of that society and that culture which
means that you're all basically
sharing the same cultural experience
you're all attached to the nation
you all understand what it means to you
now
that understanding that cultural
attachment was
vilified as racist and xenophobic by
virtually the entire
political class if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell